[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about all
things AI Silicon Valley art music
history very blessed grateful to have
dr. Peiris goofy joining us on the show
hello thank you thank you very much for
inviting me I'm very very excited you
are a role model to me and so many
others you are polymath I love calling
myself a polymath especially an aspiring
polymath over the time I have another 40
years of knowledge to collect before I
can properly call myself a a polymath
Piero is a polymath he got PhD in math
he also has is a 30 time author he is
also the founder of laser talks and he
is the founder of last Festival and I'm
super excited to be talking to Piero
about all this crazy awesome knowledge
that you've been synthesizing and
disseminating so let's jump into every
thing on everything from a big history
perspective we like doing that a lot
it's very exciting so all right we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth after a
long period of evolution and what is
your Polymathic take on what the current
state of humanity is well what everybody
sees okay first of all let's not talk
about politics which I feel sometimes is
just a distraction because you get
entangled in this story so the pooting
and Trump and she and you forget that
something else that drives the history
of the world
so what everybody notices is that this
is the century this was and is the two
centuries centuries of science and
technology right where we have more and
more surrounded by machines
I took a picture a few months ago in
China 6 a.m. with there's nobody around
that was in the subway and no I bought
the ticket from him for a machine I
bought food from machine the trigger
machine there was a machine that takes
pictures was a machine that sells toys
then to get into the subway there was a
machine checking my ticket another
machine checked my luggage and then the
subway itself these days as a robot so I
was completely surrounded by machines in
China with very few human beings around
right so that's that's the world we live
in so that's that's been been a big
change and it really started with
electricity we forget this was a major
invention when we started using
electricity just about a century ago
right then the Edison bulb is a little
older than century but cities got
electrified really a century ago and
that's that's the world we live in the
electrical world that gave gave us the
computer the smartphone all these apps
that you use but also air conditioning
that makes it you know possible to live
in extremely hot places and and then he
gave us also pollution and climate
change so everything you can think of
recently even even politics most of the
arguments are really driven by
technology science so for better for
worse medicine we live a lot longer
you know life expectancy a century ago
what was in the United States 40 41
adora mesh yeah now it's 80 doubled you
know and we have designed a babies now
also so that that's really from a global
point of view that that's what has
changed are compared with with the
previous centuries right I love it
such a good synthesis taking us into
this perspective of 200 years ago not
even having cars not even having
photography not of course not having
airplanes computers and Internet but not
and of course now walking being at this
train station and doing everything with
machines is a hue
transition massive transition and life
expectancy being increased this longer
amount of time that we have on earth to
potentially do more creative endeavoring
of sorts and have more experiences and
emotions it's very exciting
so okay on this synthesis of reality you
you know you've read you're identifying
this trajectory that we have with
engaging with machines and also of
course if we're gonna talk you know 200
years of life expectancy we can also
talk population as well from you know
just a billion or so to 7.8 lates bro me
now yeah so with that hockey stick in in
population and now with machines
everywhere where do you see this melting
pot of machine technology and human
existence molding - yeah it's so again
this there's a an obvious pro with this
there's been a lot of benefit to the
well-being of people and it's sometimes
we forget you know we demonstrate
against some technology but we forget we
need it we desperately need it
starting from mechanics you know this
roof is not collapsing because somebody
used technology to build it properly and
buildings as as elevators you don't need
to walk up the stairs you know air
conditioning a so and so on heating so
there's obvious benefits there and then
there's obvious problems so I think
where we go next they really it's really
about how we manage these things cities
have become or first all a lot of people
moved from the countryside to the city
why because the most of technologies in
the city you know we say it in different
ways but actually what we really mean
most of technologies in the city you
know hospitals train stations on and so
now we have this big cities that that
really summarize all the benefits and
daesh's and i think the future will be
about designing better cities and better
living in the cities and I'm very
worried when we focus only on the
technology part which sometimes we do
even unconsciously you know even people
who are very humanitarian and were very
concerned about the spirit not just the
matter but then at the end of the day we
tend to be very materialistic in the way
we design cities you know that's that's
so that's also why I don't want people
to lose sight or what make humans humans
yes in your manatees yes that's why it's
called you manage technology it's starts
with tech and humanity starts with human
there's a reason so sometimes we forget
these other aspects so the future is
very challenging but not mostly I'm
optimistic I mean a Steven Pinker wrote
a book where it showed the better angels
of our yeah that we are actually more
peaceful than in the past does that mean
the future is will be even more peaceful
well top to us you know it's always up
to us we have weapons of mass
destruction we have climate change we
pollute the world then incredibly higher
rate if you travel to two countries you
see it better okay in developed
countries were very good at hydrating
pollution recycling which actually is
another way to create different kind of
pollution so challenges but the solution
for these things you know that I think
I'm I'm also worried when we exaggerate
the danger that comes from technologists
science that's always been the case
that's always been the case we invent
the technology and we killed with that
technology if a lot of technology was
built during wars which is another topic
nobody wants to talk about that's right
but a lot of the things we use today
included the computer GPS GPS it was
invented either during World War two or
during the Cold War so you know
technology can be used for many
different ways in many different ways
but mostly we invented it because we
didn't want to live in the cold and dark
caves you know as we used to not that
long ago here I love talking to you so
much because you speak like a true
synthesizer of these crucial junctions
and human evolution synthesizing them
making them relatable for other people I
love the way your story tell it's very
interesting that you point out that
these next seven billion humans and the
machines that we've piled on to earth
have caused these disruptions as we've
done things like anthropogenic climate
influence like we've had with the way
that we now you know technology versus
humanities so actually understanding the
heart centric thinking the human empathy
and care that we have for each other in
this Union on earth actually making sure
that that humans can carry that and pass
it down to their children and whatnot
okay so I feel I want to ask you about
that as you know prior to this next
movement in the conversation what can we
do best about that heart centric
thinking that empathizing how do we
scale our ethics and our collective to
being all a billion humans fortunately
unfortunately that depends on what your
vision of a good societies and again so
what I don't like but that's my personal
opinion
is that sometimes we see too much the
material aspect of society I do want
people to live longer
I do want everybody to have access 12
care I do want people to have heating
and air-conditioning so you can live a
comfortable life but that's all material
stuff and I don't think that what makes
humans humans you know human humans to
me are also and maybe mainly Homer
Shakespeare Monet and so on Beethoven
and so on if you remove all these
pictures of resna
Charles Aznavour okay for their the fan
of French chanson yay
so if we remove all of this from the
history of humankind what is left is
robots damn so so that's something we do
so Deena in the world in the history of
humans in whatever you want to call it
there's always been these two forces so
there's a force that wants to structure
society
okay publicity as a book titled
intelligence is not artificial which was
originally about AI demystifying a I
then I started realizing that as people
talk about the machines taking over
which is not happening anytime soon but
they confuse two issues I mean we have
more and more machines but even before
machines even without machines is we
humans who like to structure things we
have traffic lights because we want
traffic to be ordered we want we want it
to be easy other dresses in the world
don't have traffic lights and they have
their own experience with right yes
right so we stretch a society and we
invented so many rules and regulations
in fact people will come from
totalitarian countries to the United
States sometimes they say you guys have
more rules in my country why because in
this country can decide if we were as a
city better or not yes mandatory period
okay here we have rules regulation for
everything I hike mountains when you
hike a mountain they give you a little
piece of paper that has all the rules of
regulation for walking on the mountain
and somebody from a developed developing
country will laugh I mean you have rules
to walk in the mountain either permit -
I came out in in this country so this is
for see society that wants to stretch
her life a lot
forget about machines all the things I
mentioned right now don't imply that you
need a machine to do that the machine
comes later later because you have
forced so many rules of regulations then
it becomes natural to say why don't we
have a machine enforce it why don't we
have a machine doing it okay so there's
a force in society they wants to create
what I call the vast algorri
make bureaucracy hurt but the new
edition of the book the fabric I
emphasize this aspect because we blame
machines for things that we humans want
to have widow without machines you know
we just want to have rules and
regulations why it makes life easier you
know so this one one force is that force
but I think if that force winds what we
create is the vast algorithmic
algorithmic bureaucracy where there's no
difference between a machine and human
being we lost Beethoven and Shakespeare
and so on okay so my personal very
limited very small mission in this you
know movement is to remind people that
music is great and painting is great and
sculpture is great comic books are great
video games are great rock music is
great you know all these things I want
to lose them personal opinion okay if
you like a society where we behave like
robots we're getting there
okay when you call I was a kid I was
calling somebody some service there was
a human being and then I would get
annoyed because this person is in a bad
mood I need something done and whatever
we yell at each other whatever that was
a human interaction we solved the
problem by making it all automated there
are rules you call and the first thing
is press one for English press 2 for
Spanish 1 press 1 for this press 1 and
so on
right and eventually you get to
something that tells you what currently
closed call back later whatever so so in
all of this you're slowly becoming a
machine you're interacting with machines
and you are asked to be a machine ok so
I don't like that personal opinion ok I
liked it whoa yeah this is really
interesting to talk about with you
because I don't think other people that
have been on our program yet have been
able to synthesize the state of humanity
to this extent that you also as you
carry the humanities
with you even having Douglas rushkoff
recently on the show talking about team
human you synthesized the humanities in
a way that really expresses what makes
us human and then on top of that you
also explain how this this vast
algorithmic bureaucracy is what is
machining and robotic robot a sizing us
in many ways and potentially you're
indicating to us kind of the decrease in
humanity as the vast algorithmic
bureaucracy increases and so if we're
starting to behave with the with the
everything in a way that is robot size
how do we then properly empathize how do
we then properly know how to engage with
the child how do we properly know how to
engage with the with someone that is
hurt or depressed or how do we engage
with our loved ones that are going
through a period of turmoil or
potentially death how do we have these
deep human instincts that have been with
us for hundreds of thousands million
years those are what makes us human and
it's just very beautiful the way that
you speak about that human in that
technology I feel like ron has a as a
contribution
no okay not yet not yet okay cool
all right Pierre let's uh let's talk a
bit on you know you listed all these
things that you're obsessed with rock
music our history also technology having
people understand why you care so much
about music and why it makes us human
it's centered teach us about that so
that so that's another aspect the same
thing the other thing we miss if we only
look at technology and science is the
very history of why things happened and
so when my friend Aruna suggests that I
write a history of Silicon Valley I've
been in Silicon Valley since 83 okay I
thought it was incredibly stupid idea
people in Silicon Valley don't want to
read about the past they just want to
hear where should I invest next and
people outside in those days Silicon
Valley was not that famous
was before the TV series before the
movies on Steve Jobs and Zuckerberg but
then I wrote it because I realized
people miss the point you know when
people talk about Silicon Valley they
always talk about what for so they talk
about the billionaires who to me and an
effect not the cost that just the lucky
ones and secondly if you are if you
start asking them why it happened here
in in that in that valley far away from
New York land and so on they start
telling you for this reason for that
reason for that reason those reasons you
know if those are the reasons you should
ever happen in Walled near Wall Street
or near or near the city of London the
money was there the big electronic
companies were there all the winners
Nobel Prizes were there and most
importantly governments were spending a
lot there so that that doesn't work
why did San Frisco Bay Area ended up
being the the technology hub of the
world you know we goo Google number one
in his field Facebook is number one in
his field Intel is number one in its
field Airbnb uber we have biotech we
have everything you know and there was
nothing here in the 50s there were all
charts and people missed the point they
start listing factors coming from Europe
I mean Germany was doing the same things
two centuries ago so that doesn't
explain Stanford doesn't explain it was
a small university back then but if you
look at the society what was special
about the Bay Area in the 50s and then
in 60s and still is to some extent bunch
of crazy people you go back before
technology became a big thing here San
Francisco Bay Area was famous as a
refuge for crazy artists for crazy
writers not the best ones the craziest
ones crazy politicians crazy whatever it
was a place where if you think different
you're cool in the rest of the world
you're homeless and jobless okay this
was a place where if you wear shorts and
t-shirt you are normal Wall Street
you're fired
okay so that was was really unique about
this area technology then came by
accident because of the war who cares
why it came from the people here look at
the technology did something different
with it
okay my favorite example is the internet
that was invented by the DARPA
Department of Defense it was a tool to
survive the cold war comes here people
use it as social media today is called
social media we start saying I was
working in it when it was called ARPANET
and we were using it to organize parties
and to discuss rock music okay this is a
place what these things happen and then
it turns out the whole world likes it
actually if you use technology that way
the whole world does millions of special
young people who like it so if you don't
mix the culture the society in the
history of Technology you totally missed
the point you know I read so many books
about Silicon Valley that totally
ridiculous they start by saying oh the
Gaza Valley as Silicon Valley as ABC men
those things even in Italy we add them
Germany had the ten times more you know
you don't explain why only this place
became so big the rest of the world is
trying to copy Silicon Valley from
Malaysia to China to Europe whatever
they all fail why the society is
different you can't have the same thing
and the government had nothing to do
with it
I keep trying to explain to people
around the world Washington didn't even
know the Silicon Valley existed I
imagine one day somebody told the
president something about Silicon Valley
the president was reading the New York
Times or The Wall Street Journal
depending if it was that Democrat or
Republican and what's Silicon Valley
okay Washington was the last one to know
that Silicon Valley was happening it was
the society that created the Silicon
Valley so when governments around the
world tried to build Silicon Valley I
laugh the very starting point is wrong
okay you have to study Society and of
course rock music was very important you
know there was rock music before the
whole Silicon Valley not the other way
around
do you have a favorite rock band Piera
that you like I have many favorite rock
bands
when a plane rolling stone' the CDC
those are great but I started with the
ones that were less famous I started
with the Velvet Underground the most
influential band you read in Europe
Faust the Canterbury band soft machine
and so on so long story do you like yes
yes - but better ones come on buy my
book 1000 pages i thickest the book if
you go and look at
Piero's websites scarfy comets links in
the bio below if you go and look at it
you'll see 10,000 pages written with
BIOS reviews lists history on music and
that is only the start of his interest
in music then he started telling you a
bit on his profound synthesis on the
house Silicon Valley emerged how then
now we need to embed that the human
values into our technology as we move
forward and just just having this lens
of a real raw perspective on how Silicon
Valley became what it did and also how
other places in the world are interested
in that process is very fascinating and
however we end up embedding human values
these things that you care so much about
music our history all these different
humanities into technology how culture
picked it up like you were saying when
at the times of ARPANET it's about
surviving that DARPA is making this
surviving through the Cold War making
communication systems now we take the
hundred 50 times that we grab this thing
per day and instantly send people
messages and video chats as the main we
reboot brought our baseline up and
that's now that's what we that's what we
reason for so it can be difficult
sometimes to rap only a 10 year old or a
30 year old mind into this past into
getting behind the eyes of humans that
built civilization not only from 10,000
years ago agriculture but all the way up
to even DARPA and ARPANET but if you see
if you like what's in that little device
if you think that's useful you have to
realize what it came from and it doesn't
just come from somebody building a
computer it really comes from all these
crazy ideas floating around and really
you miss we can't write history anymore
because we separated text science from
from the humanities but think ok if you
don't believe my story about Silicon
Valley fine some people don't believe it
but let's go back one century but if you
think today we have a lot of progress
that's not a sign that you didn't study
history about between eighteen eighteen
nineteen twenty in those forty years the
car was invented the airplane was
invented the telephone became it wasn't
mad a little earlier but that's the age
of the telephone the phonograph was
invented cinema was invented I mean you
could hear the voice of somebody was
dead you could call your mother and
speak to your mother
3,000 kilometers away humans were flying
all of this happen in those 40 years in
the same 40 years relativity quantum
mechanics skyscrapers invented pretty
much all the appliances you can think of
refrigerator washing machine whatever
invented there what was special about
those 40 years guess what
Impressionism Expressionism the
literature just about every art you can
think of had a boom
guess what technology and science had a
boom so Renaissance Italian Renaissance
I won't talk about it early because
sounds boring but Renaissance wasn't
just Michelangelo was also about the
Leonardo and Deng Galileo right
Italy was a poor country in those day it
wasn't even a country was fractured in
hundreds of small states fighting each
other all the time with plagues
invasions from the northern pleasure
guess what it has the Renaissance
great artists great science great tech
so when the society is creative a
society's creative period in art in tech
in science and then you get a smartphone
well does they support you got some
other technology but so now that if we
separate the two things we can't even
tell the story of how these things
developed these things developed because
people were very creative they were
thinking a lot you know and then we got
them so if we remove the humanities art
music historian sociologist from the
picture and we just have the tech in the
science we build this vast algorithmic
societies they work very well I mean
nobody will ever jaywalk again everybody
will wear seat belts you know but you
know but I don't think that would have
progress anymore we would just become
this stationary global machine that
works very well ok but it's boring
we're also we're also not quite
obviously moving in just the direction
of tech and science without any art in
history and music and sociology etc we
are embedding that as we go but maybe
even before I get there it was too
interesting when you said this that it's
the meshing of the art in the science
and the technology in these time periods
like the Renaissance Michelangelo da
Vinci Galileo it was at the times of
things like the 1880s to 1920s when this
is so cool that it's everything from all
of the commercial appliances to hearing
dead people's voices in cinema to seeing
humans fly to seeing skyscrapers emerge
oh my gosh that sounds like right now it
sounds like one sec right now have have
200,000 commercial flights happening per
day that we have this video chat device
where we can see someone in China huh
but when we now are using Jessie in
Euros and why these are periods of great
creativity it's incredible quickly
people adopt new technology you tend to
think oh this much people adopt new
technology not ordinary people ordinary
people go out and and in Louisville
radios and light and live photographs
and so on it spread very quickly in the
book I calculate I think 49 years
because that's when 49 years ago we
invented the first autonomous robot okay
and then I calculate how many robots we
have today and I show in 49 years how
many radios we had 49 years after the
invention already how many radios we had
how many airplanes we had there was also
amazing I hope people adopt quickly
things yeah because in a period of 50
years we went like boom was already own
society that is relevant the whole
society wants something and then then it
happens very quickly but again let's not
forget that a lot of the motivation
comes from all these crazy artists and
crazy musicians yes
most of which will never make money okay
we only that's the battery is true we
only remember history books I hate at
the history books they only talk about
the people who started wars politicians
and the people who became rich and they
forget everybody else you know that's
that's a pity because were the ones that
did the art Tech in science that built
all these cool inventions that we now
have enough adoption rates are just like
so people everybody contributed and even
in Silicon Valley a lot of the people
who were engineers but they work in they
were really working in the garage and
two or three became famous but there
were a lot of them working in the garage
chefs were just for fun most of the
great history of Silicon Valley are
people just wanted to build something
for fun or for themselves you know and
some of them became rich two or three
became rich but a lot of them didn't but
you have to think everybody so even the
engineers were actually not just
engineers they were engineers but with
crazy ideas that's an artist that you
enjoy this perspective on thing
I think this idea that it's something
called like behind the groove for music
so for all the for all of the artists
that we see in today spotlight for all
of the actress for all of the the
prominent CEOs of these businesses that
we see across the world behind the
groove is the thousands of people these
thousands of musicians that helped us
all the audio engineers and all of the
in the technology industry all the
designers and the engineers on the
software side of things as well just the
people that helped make the things that
we use on a daily basis are behind the
groove and they're not severely getting
that beautiful light but it also comes
from just people's wanting to contribute
of something of meaning and value I love
I love that art science and tech and
then that that in those in these
different time periods has unleashed so
much beauty into our world but actually
what's interesting is that back in 1500
and back in early 1900 Lindy's happened
that there were only like a couple
million people to kind of get on maybe
tens of millions of people get on board
now we see the billion get on board with
certain things that are being made and
that number is that's a lot of new
training algorithms again it's
transitioning us into those are you are
you quite realistic or optimistic where
do you we're optimistic where do you sit
on the seeing where that should with the
with the embedding human values into the
technology that we make well so so when
I start with the lasers I start to the
ladies in 2008 right I was putting
together artist and scientist I was
honestly worried so that actually I was
doing salons before that so it started
even earlier I was worried also because
education was so much STEM science
technology engineering not not
humanities not a theme right
and and then I lived in Silicon Valley
so although these engineers suddenly
Silicon Valley went from being everybody
crazy engineer to being more corporate
so I was getting a little worried today
I'm more optimistic because actually all
this technology that we created
especially online makes it very easy to
mix art and tech so you see you know
even AI there people are working in deep
learning realize that with neural
networks you can actually do really cool
I don't want to call that paintings how
you call them you know this these things
in section is somebody a deal of deep
fakes right yeah well the defects are
the bad application of it but neural
networks can generate facial recognition
that generate these paintings that look
like paintings are not paintings you
know surreal things so it's become more
natural easier to use tech to do art
which means being creative so I can see
a way that the two things will work
together mildly optimistic by the end of
the a at the end at the end of the day
it's hard to predict our human society
balls how our brain evolves so I don't
know I just again my small contribution
is to try to remind people when so the
laces of for talks right you've spoken
at one you've seen how it works they
have four I invited four speakers on
four different disciplines on four
different topics I make a point knowing
no intersection okay 20 minutes 20
minutes 20 minutes 20 minutes a lot of
the people who come people are not
familiar with the format come to listen
to one of the four and appropriate know
that there are three other people
thought the best compliment I get is
when somebody walks out of the room and
tells me Pierre I had no idea okay he
came to listen to you
Alan and I force him to listen to the
physicist and I force him to listen to
the painter yes okay for since nice
record it goes home knowing her there's
more than just Alan
or there's more than just physics or
does more than just you know it came for
one thing and also interestingly can
when they leave and they go now I see a
new way how physics and painting are
right yes so so that's that's my
contribution you know try to remind
people there's a lot more and then
slowly people get it that all of these
factors are important in shaping your
world yes and then depends on you how
much you want of this intersection but
technology does not happen in a vacuum
your smartphone was not born in a vacuum
was born in a society that a lot of
things and in my opinion luckily this
society had really a lot of stuff going
on the hippies the punks later Burning
Man
you know there was so much going on
survival research labs on how many
people are familiar with these things
all of this shaped the culture survival
research labs those are the machines
that destroy yeah is that there that's
that's them yeah
in the 80s San Francisco a lot of empty
warehouses people were experimenting all
sort of free events all of this shape
the minds here you know so all these
things is important again essentially go
the impressionist painters did the crazy
things the money money I was confused my
name Monet as a painting where they say
the sky is curved that's two or three
years before Einstein comes out of
relativity and space and a curved
space-time these things are important
yes
you know silly things in the new book I
wrote these things because they're
obvious to me but they're not obvious if
you only study technology AI was
invented 1955 when was when did rock and
roll start 1955 is it a coincidence you
know dead here for a number of reasons
people were ready for new ideas but rock
music rock music comes from Whitman
blues from the thirties forties whatever
ai comes from girdle and some other
people on that but the names and and the
big phenomenal starts in 1955 what
start at the same time you know now if
you only study one you will never notice
the coincidence there's no coincidence
in history that's the statement I made
there's no coincidence if you look at
the society something was going on in
society after World War two mines were
open mines were ready for things
cinnamon was doing the juvenile
delinquents and lots of things going on
in the art abstract art was being born
and so on guess what the rock'n'roll is
born
ai is born the same here okay it's in my
opinion you can't have one without the
other
if you think there's some benefit from
this one you can't ignore that that it's
the prod of the society that was doing a
lot of creative things you remove all
the creative things I don't know what
you get but I don't think I would like
it because we were on the panel with
Maya and Alicia is making music
artificially intelligent composition of
music and when that's happening and it
can go through billions of permutations
in the span of just a couple of hours
where humans had to take decades to be
able to do and when we do that same
thing with painting and that same thing
with sculpting and the same thing with
with all different styles of music and
book writing and article writing and
well what happens then with the
humanities when that a machine that is
passing the Turing test is able to
empathize with me as a as a patient at a
clinic better than a nurse potentially
can that what is left and where is the
humanity then is this the next evolution
the arrow is this is this artificial
general intelligence
the next evolution that were seeing I
wish I wish this was true it's true only
in Hollywood movies unfortunately what I
see is the opposite it's us forced to
live with incredibly stupid machines
when you buy a ticket from the Machine
you are forced to behave like a machine
you can talk too much you can just tell
the Machine hey I want to go to Berkeley
oh I need to
not you're saying not us not yet not yet
then it goes okay google buy me a ticket
to San Mateo on the Cal train
yeah but you have to simplify the center
you have to simply Alexa turn on the
light that's where we are we are
coexisting with incredibly sweetly
machines and that's scary you know I
want the machine to adapt to us not
vice-versa
the voice is that voices machines
adapting to humans we're no longer gonna
press these meat sticks on the keyboards
and stuff we're gonna use voice pyram
spatial intelligence spatial design yeah
we can add it I'm going to use voice but
see these things have been tried that
twenty years ago I was in a Singapore
and they were trying this this elevator
voice-activated you say - we goes to a
second floor unfortunately if I'm having
a conversation with you and I use the
word - it will go to the second floor
okay now we have hotels soil tell in
China where you walk in by the way
there's a robot that takes you to the
hotel you walk into to the elevator you
walk into the elevator the elevator
automatically goes to your room because
it senses the card correct okay yeah
unfortunately if I want when I wanted to
go visit my friend at another floor I
couldn't go there first the elevator
only takes you to your floor into the
first floor
yes so we are introducing a lot of
incredibly stupid machines that we have
to deal with them but because this is
the learning curve just like when the
humans were dying when they were first
trying to fly airplanes just like when
they were dying when they were first
transplanting organs into human bodies
in a sense even the fast and seatbelts I
do fasten seatbelts on on a highway but
I would like to add the freedom to
decide when it makes sense if I get in
my car and I'm just moving it from the
driveway to the street course doesn't
make sense the car goes beep-beep-beep
I cannot explain to the car that I'm not
okay I'm not doing anything dangerous
there's nobody around okay so I'm afraid
for now the world that is coming right
now and probably in the foreseeable
future
is a word
incredibly stupid machine however lives
them and they're scary to see the
younger generations that accepted
passively okay I can see advantages in
using the old VHS tape over the DVD
certainly over the live streaming that
sometimes stops suddenly in the middle
of what I'm watching the younger
generation has never seen the VHS tape
it doesn't know that can rewind it
exactly to the scene I want to see yes
okay we miss something there okay so so
what is scary is that we adapting we are
adapting to dumb to machines
okay if the very intelligent machines
come it will just be another pet we've
always said intelligent intelligence
around us there is non-human dogs can do
things you cannot do my favorite example
is the bat the bat can fly in the dark
can catch insects and can land the
upside down on the ceiling can you do
that yes so you know if you if you bring
another intelligence in the picture okay
what's wrong with that I lived with bats
I lived with dogs I live with cats some
of them are dangerous and we live with
lions and tigers we survive will survive
intelligent machines am more afraid of
the opposite of millions of millions of
very stupid machines that force me to do
stupid things like I've done this
morning to buy the ticket the BART
ticket you know you have to deduct money
then you have to then you have to press
the right button okay but you're making
fun of all the stupid aspects of the
tech this is like looking at all the
lame ways that humans used to transit oh
it used to be such a hassle to use the
Ford Model T now look we have these
amazing cars that have cruise control
and yada yada so this is just the this
is the evolution of what we do with the
technology that we engage with is that
it gives better over time as we use it
we go through the processes of the
machines being a little stupider then
they become a little smarter over time
then even smarter for example pierrot we
want you to be a polymath longer to
teach people longer to have more life so
you can
express yourself but the way to do that
is to be able to monitor things like
your entire biometrics and have
preventive health care these are very
important things yes but no machine will
make mistakes that I said from the
beginning of that some we underestimate
all the value we get from technology I'm
just saying in the near future if you
ask me indirectly you were you were
basically pointed to a future where
machines are very intelligent you know
and I was telling you that danger I see
is the opposite I see a future certainly
a near future a possibly also a
long-term future of stupid machines
where we coexist with stupid machines
and we have to adapt to their stupidity
but let me tell everyone chief let me
repeat one important one important point
I am Not Afraid of a very intelligent
machine just like I'm not afraid of a
very intelligent cat it's another
intelligence that lives on this planet
and actually we simulate my intelligence
will force me to be more intelligent
just like we had we had to be more
intelligent of the tiger to survive in
the case I'm afraid of a world where we
put so many stupid machines and we have
to live with them and we start behaving
like a stupid machine okay that's option
that's that sometimes the most dangerous
place you can find yourself in is being
the smartest person in a room full of
dumb people do you understand what that
means yeah no if you if you take the
exam you know you're very intelligent
man very intelligent just trying to stay
as intelligent as I am no don't go lower
so so Pierrot illustrates this
interesting point that we could
potentially get to with machine
intelligence where the machines that we
surround ourselves with are not actually
completely intelligently optimized in
the environment that we're in this whole
Internet of Things era if some of the
things are actually making us literally
stupider because it's harder to engage
with them in the process of them
learning and growing with them yet yet I
also think that there is a very interest
the amount of we need a hefty dose of
humility because I think were hubristic
we are overly self-confident just like
we were that all the earth is the center
of the universe no no it wasn't and just
like right now we say all the technology
is not the next evolution I think again
we just need a hefty dose of humility
and understand that the ability to
crunch these trillions of variables
simultaneously about your biometrics and
give you preventive medicine is better
than you or any doctor ever or even
eight billion Minds all thinking at the
same time could potentially do and that
things like that
give us some humility and eventually the
internet-of-things environment
eventually all that hopefully will be at
the successful levels with the right
engineers designers artists yeah
fortunately jesse is eventually they
eventually the scares me because of the
law in the short term and even in the
long term
I'm afraid machines we remain pretty
stupid and the reason is that we haven't
found a way to give machines common
sense see even even a cat and a mouse of
common sense do you believe there's
something among us that doesn't want
that wants to dumb ass down Pierrot I
because that's what I fear I fear that
we have to be careful be careful with
who's programming artificial
intelligence it's safe to say you don't
have faith in AI that the machines will
always be dumb but there might be
something behind that yeah but that
wants us to be controlled and dumb and
not critical thinkers yeah and this is
something that people don't yeah that's
the but that's that's what is happening
right that's how technology is being
used what is behind number wrong number
one is about the number one position Oh
who's behind you don't you think if we
knew the number one application of AI so
far most successful application of AI is
making you buy things you don't need you
know that's that's how we the number one
use of this new algorithm is making you
buy things you don't need you know all
these recommendation algorithm
so you know and then this you know of
course governments use technology to
build the best algorithmic bureaucracy
so you know but it's the human
intelligence behind this it's really the
human intelligent we're talking about
the Machine so again I'm there's
something that very few people say I'm
not afraid of an intelligent machine a
really intelligent machine with a
machine that I can have this
conversation with what's wrong with that
it's just another intelligence on the
planet and I think it would be different
from us I'm a skeptic that will happen
anytime soon because we haven't found a
way to equip machines with common sense
so the same exact self-driving the
self-driving car is readily becoming a
joke it's the self crashing car and
there are very few sub driving cars and
already three people died
we don't serve in Arizona they throw
stones at the cemetery don't don't
nitpick your data points though because
you can also pick the data points where
the vehicle is seeing better in the fog
or it's making an advanced decision
about swerving out of the way I know
what you cannot doing not doing new you
just give me another device in my car
while I'm driving
that helps me that warns me about
dangerous whatever I'm very happy but if
you give me a self-driving car which
means now the car is in charge of
driving by itself in real traffic that's
scary that that car is no common sense
so it will it will make mistakes that we
don't make we make many mistakes my
favorite example is just face
recognition if there's a crowd and I see
somebody looks like you I may go eh
Allen oh it was an Allen yes but that's
a legitimate mistake we have machines
that look at the face and say this is a
refrigerator that's not a legitimate
mistake so I'm scared of that machine it
makes that mistake only once in a
million I make my mistakes once in in 10
times ok fine but my illegitimate
mistakes I was telling a friend as we
were hiking because it hurt with your
permit of course with my turn
we thought it there was a bear and it
was a tree and he said I must
would never make the mistake and then I
thought right but I will not trust
hiking with a machine that doesn't make
that mistake because that could be a
bear
I want a machine that makes the same
mistake I make and tells me hey Pierre
that could be a bear okay it's not a
very so tree my body didn't so I trust
my body okay
so common sense is hard to quantify yes
it is very but but that's the thing that
I still see missing in machines and
until somebody shows a machine with
comments or concerns I don't believe we
have intelligent machines coming we have
to be machines come the more we give
them the scare the more afraid I am okay
that's my point that's a very
interesting point on the comment I've
been in the eye since 1980 yes yes of
course of course of course this is why
when we when we break down the nuance
with guests on the show it's super
important to hear the edge of knowledge
that the guest has been experiencing for
a long period of time I like how you
talk about the COG the lack of common
sense the fact that you want it to make
the mistake is that a bear we want to
that that's that's a very interesting
point and I think there's a lot of
creativity that's being explored with
great amounts of permutation capacity
that humans can't yet and we see it
happening in go we see it happening in
chess jeopardy and alpha star and
there's a bunch of alpha zero and it's
just very interesting to see it to see
it unfolding and hopefully by hopefully
by a 2100 there will be some smarter
machines let's say let's hope let's hope
for that hero's crate 2100 yeah how many
years
I don't know Ray Kurzweil sand and
actually a lot of the of the leading
artificial intelligence scientists on
the planet actually think that we'll get
to an artificial general intelligence
the average is 2047 as their current
average predicted which if they're still
alive that we just change the definition
intelligence that's the easy way to
declare victory
mission accomplished you just change the
definition
yeah very interesting Piero there's so
much wisdom to still to ask you
questions that still learn from you on
the show the couple quick questions on
the way out that we want to ask you okay
you talk so much on art science and tech
mix together how can we best absorb that
you know you have your laser talks and
that's going on in 38 cities everyone
there have been over 1,000 talks
delivered so you can find all that
information in the links below that's a
great place to get this art science and
tech mix but and your last festival and
stuff but how can one and as an adult
and also teaching kids embody this
mentality of art science and tech as
something that they move themselves into
the future with I don't know what would
be a good principle to recommend
everybody's different everybody's
different I don't know it's it's each
life story's different I think I think
if you're curious
it should come natural you know your
problems sometimes you don't have the
opportunity so exactly I mean some minor
is a small contribution as you know the
lasers and the last festive are hobbies
right they're not my full-time job it's
much more contribution to give the
opportunity to people to learn more
about sensory I think there should be a
lot more free talks agreed so I like
that Stanford UC Berkeley have so many
open events where anybody can go yeah I
can I can all encourage people to go to
events free events read books there's a
lot of good books and that's right yeah
curiosity yeah and then having the time
yeah and my curiosity no somebody else's
Curos you know somebody else would
invite a different speaker together yes
yes so you know it's really young people
ask me this question a lot and I really
don't know I really don't know the
answer just be curious and be curious
yeah towards whatever is passionately
grabbing you how about a core driving
principle of your life
don't be afraid of new ideas you know I
tend to see new ideas as new
opportunities I study history us study
history that's very important my god I
don't know if history repeats itself who
never repeats itself it is an endless
discussion but you learn a lot by
studying history it really opens your
mind a lot about everything you know you
see everything with different different
eyes yeah the history is always that
needs to be interpreted by the more you
study history the more you get facts and
these facts form your own opinion
honestly so cause I I see where Ron is
going value facts can be distorted some
facts can be hidden some fact that's the
good historian is the historian who digs
up the facts that have been swept under
the carpet years and then there's new
relevance to things are big for God
that's the archeology I love that side
of things because there's so many still
artifacts and data points that have
better being disappearing or even humans
are very recent very recent history I
mean now that the Soviet archives are
open it's amazing how different the
Soviet Union looks like in also
interesting we look worse by the way
because they were not as evil as we
thought and thought so if even recently
history you can find can can make you
think differently that may become a
reoccurring theme about the United
States is that the places that we fought
against may not have been as evil as
potentially and some of our friends were
probably more evil but that's not that's
not surprised yes we tend to like
friends excused actions of friends and
and that demonize the actual
surveillance that's not correct hey
that's okay and then last you wouldn't
be simulation if we didn't ask you are
we in a simulation nah I don't think so
why well you have to show me dislike
asking does God exist show me God then I
say yes show me the scene show me
evidence of the simulation and say yes
until the day I don't think so
okay I will build the simulation out and
show you that fast-forward 13.8 billion
years and show you where here okay and
how about last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world thing not not people pick
otherwise I have to answer my wife
people are included if you're just
talking about things in the universe
probably I still think the same way I
thought when I was a child stars in
those days I didn't know what stars are
but I was fascinated I think still if
you look at the Stars focus on what's up
there it's scary but it's also somehow
accelerator height and dwarfing of the
ego so much curve from that yes and it's
interesting to think what do we have in
common with other planets yes and
probably the one thing we have in common
is that everybody looks at the stars and
yeah so one thing we are in common with
any other sentient being right and that
math and physics in those areas is also
likely being computed similarly data I
would I would love to meet people from
another planet and see if they develop
the same kind of science faculties with
the perception and y'all different stuff
yeah for another conversation peer a
holy cow this has been super filled with
lots of awesome saturation polymathics
saturation I love it thank you for
coming on thank you go enjoy anything
super pleasure the question super
pleasure I mean your sessions with you
are a blessing and I hope others feel
this way - thank you everyone for tuning
and we greatly appreciate you we'd love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below let us know what you were thinking
about the conversation also check out
Piero's links below go and check them
out go to a laser talk near you check
out scruffy comm see what's on there
check out the music go and have more
conversations about art about tech about
science around you and inspire more
people to build the future everyone's
support artists and entrepreneurs that
you believe in and our links are below
as well
and much love thank you Ron for
producing and directing thanks everyone
thank you long in yeah and what's a
Venetian on this show soon okay okay
good
all right much love everyone we'll see
you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]